qui m'a demandé votre obéissant serviteur
ami ou pas ami et pas ami et pas mariée
ou en dessous d'eux, je suis le président de la Russie
fédérations
[la musique]
nous poursuivrons les arrestations partout dans
aéroport à l'aéroport signifie que tu es déjà moi
désolé dans les toilettes on va attraper et et
et dans les toilettes ils sont torturés à la fin tout
la question est enfin close tout d'abord
La Russie a été et sera bien sûr
la plus grande nation européenne
[la musique]
recherche de talon automatique
11 notes et sous les baskets que daniel et tankanul
[la musique]
vous devez vous déshabiller à d'autres endroits sur leur
comment et où d'autre sur les plages nudistes
[la musique]
mais
[applaudissements]
[la musique]
pour